diese frage spaltet nehme ich das land
seitdem der innensenator und seitdem die
berliner hört behörden eben heute dieses
anti corona demo verbot verkündet haben
und diese frage zwischen freiheit
zwischen grundrechten und
infektionsschutzgesetz die wollen wir
hier im studio und zugeschaltet
diskutieren mit sebastian czaja bei mir
dem fdp politiker aus berlin außerdem
mit karl lauterbach dem ihn vermutlich
bekannten spd gesundheitspolitiker und
auch mit dem focus kolumnisten jan
fleischhauer also eine muntere und bunte
runde die erste frage an den lauterbach
der der rote oder rot rote senat in
berlin der verkündet dieses
demonstrationsverbot dieses
versammlungsverbot weil ihm die leute
nicht gefallen die da auf die straße
gehen nein das ist nicht der grund also
die leute ob die gefahr oder nicht
spielt überhaupt keine rolle sondern
hier handelt es sich um eine
demonstration wo angekündigt beweise
gegen die ohne schutz vorschriften
verstoßen würde
in der tat der protest gegen diese
schutzvorschriften ist genau weshalb
überhaupt demonstriert wird
und da damit zu rechnen ist dass also
die schutzvorschriften daher nicht
eingehalten werden wäre die teilnahme an
der demonstration durch große
menschenmengen eine gefährdung anderer
hinter jene sind ja ich woher wissen sie
dass das so gefährlich ist und
gefährlicher als bei anderen
demonstrationen haben sie den angeboten
dass wir möglicherweise im weg gewesen
vorne am eingangstor oder an den
umliegenden straßen mundschutz
auszugeben oder ist das völliger quatsch
in die realität zeigt davon der also
demonstrationen die ich schon
stattgefunden hat dass die gegner läuft
nur dass du nicht bereit sind in der tat
die ganze demonstration wäre ja sinnlos
wenn die leute dort mit mundschutz
auftreten würden sie würde ich ja selbst
widersprechen das ist ja nicht nur so zu
erwarten dass jemand gegen den
mundschutz demonstriert und nach denen
beispielsweise damit würden wir das
erwarten können was also jeder normale
mensch erwartet dass der zweck der
demonstration noch demonstriert wird in
dem man sich genauso feiert ja verstehen
relativ rücksichtslos verstehen reicht
ihnen das die bloße annahme dass die
sich da am
ende alle gegen die regeln verhalten
würden reicht allein diese annahme um zu
sagen dann dürft ihr halt nicht
demonstrieren
der artikel 8 unseres grundgesetzes gibt
jedem das recht auch zu demonstrieren
für seine meinung für seine position
einzutreten und deshalb hätte ich
zuallererst vom innensenator erwartet
dass er klare auflagen macht klare
regeln definiert und wenn dann diese
regeln tatsächlich gebrochen werden dass
so eine versammlung dann unterbunden und
abgebrochen wird das wäre aus meiner
sicht der richtige weg gewesen
herr geißler hat sich hier unnötig in
einer debatte zum programmdirektor auf
gespielt und hat eine entscheidung
getroffen die nur dazu führt dass sich
die fronten verhärten wo es jetzt so
wichtig ist dass man gerade wenn es um
grundrechte um freiheitsrechte geht aber
auch um gesundheit und hygiene schutz
gemeinsam in dieser gesellschaft
miteinander bringt und um lösung statt
an nochmal der fleischhauer herr
lauterbach sagt na ja das ist doch
völlig klar die werden da halt keinen
mundschutz tragen die werden da ganz
ganz bewusst die regeln brechen am
wochenende dann lassen wir die halt
nicht auflaufen was antworten sie ein
lauterbach zeichen für ein geistig
fitter entscheidenden teil hat nun eine
zweite begründung geliefert
schriftlichen hat gesagt ich werde es
nicht hinnehmen dass hier in berlin noch
mal die bühne geboten wird corona läuft
nun reichs bürgern überhaupt allen heute
hier das falsche glauben und das ehrlich
das ist für ein innensenator der von dem
ich denke jetzt auf die verfassung
vereidigt ist der erstaunliche aussage
über den bug kumpel denn da hin dass in
berlin offenbar nehme ich nicht nur der
infektionsschutz darüber entscheidet ob
leute auf die straße gehen dürfen nicht
und da hatte man das gefühl dass da mit
zweierlei maß gemessen mit allerdings
gegen lag live ist für blacklight
matters ist und gegen rassismus dann
sagen als auch in der partei von
lauterbach der spd juhu das wäre toll
selbst dann da auch der abstand wie wir
hier sehen ich glaube das ist ein
blackout mittags demo
man sich gar nicht eingehalten wird aber
das wahlgeschenk nein aber zu sagen dass
er die villa erst mal von von vor drei
wochen aber wir können auch gleich
bilder von blackwater zeigen die sie
erwähnen die großdemonstration in berlin
der fleischhauer tatsächlich zweierlei
maß ist der vorwurf khalatbari
diesen vorwurf kriegen sie doch gar
nicht weg das liegt doch auf der hand
der vorwurf war so ist aus meiner sicht
für mich zumindest unberechtigt weil ich
habe auch die black stars matt also
demonstration genauso gewürdigt wie das
was jetzt also beobachten ist wobei
übrigens ganz recht hätten sie auch
verboten sie hätten ja auch verboten
ich hätte auf jeden fall die auflagen
also gemacht und also wenn dann die
ankündigung gewesen und wäre wir halten
uns nicht an die auflagen damit ist
sowohl wenn die auflagen vorher
angekündigt worden wir werden sagen wir
die big blast meter vor demonstranten
also gesagt hätten wir erhalten uns auf
die an die auflage und es wäre dann
nicht sehen gewesen dann hätte ich es
aufgelöst aber ihr sehr die
sondersituation das und vornherein
gesagt wird wir demonstrieren gegen die
maßen sich die frage haben wir uns heute
gestellt das können weiß vielleicht
sebastian czaja weil er die diskussion
noch näher in berlin verfolgt hat dass
da überhaupt gespräche gegeben doch mal
mit den organisatoren und die haben ganz
klar gesagt ja wir werden uns hier an
überhaupt nichts halten
für uns als als politiker hier in der
stadt im landesparlament ist es völlig
unklar ob es das gegeben hat oder nicht
das hätten wir aber erwartet dass genau
das passiert und mit der begründung mit
der diese demonstration abgesagt wurde
wird halt eben genau der konflikt weiter
geschürt und herr fleischhauer hat eben
völlig zu recht noch mal zitiert und
eigentlich müsste sich herr lauterbach
davon auch distanzieren dass ein
innensenator der auf die verfassung
vereidigt ist mit solch einer
argumentation eine demonstration ab
sagten sie dass distanzieren sie sich
davon denn tatsächlich sind diese worte
hergefallen herr lauterbach herr geißler
hat ja nicht nur oder nicht
ausschließlich gesagt wegen der zu
befürchtenden regelbrüche wegen des
infektionsschutzgesetzes verbiete ich
diese demonstration sondern hat er sehr
wohl
eine politische motivation durchaus in
seiner begründung mit einfließen lassen
also wenn da zusätzlich mit wenn
zusätzlich andere politische begründung
gegeben wurde dann ist das die position
von der geißel da ist es nicht an mir
lassen kritisiert aber mir reicht
ehrlich gesagt der erste teil das was er
gesagt hat das ist das was ich teile zu
können
es wäre an ihnen das zu kritisieren sie
dürfen dass hierbei bilden sie das wiso
wäre das an mir ehrlich gesagt das ist
eine äußerung die hier sage ich mal von
der eigentlichen substanz doch ablenken
das ist eine demonstration die die
allgemeine gesundheit unsere erfolge in
der pandemie gefährt vom gefährdet sind
eine situation derzeit die größte mühe
haben group es gab auch in berlin
die kinder wieder einigermaßen sicher in
die schule zu bringen
das wird sogar diskutiert dass wir am
arbeitsplatz die maske tragen müssten
und gleichzeitig wurde ich dann zu sagen
diesen demonstranten erlauben ohne jeden
schutz sich gegenseitig und andere
gefährden so dass die infektionszahlen
weiter steigen dann ist ein clown haben
der auch daran ist solche wenn eine
solche situation zugelassen wird dann
nimmt der staat seine eigenen regeln ich
ernst und greift entsprechend nicht im
sinne der bürger durch wir verlieren
hier durch einige wenige die sich
unvernünftig verhalten sind um uns nicht
nur diese demonstranten sondern es sind
natürlich auch sehr viele andere die
sich entfalten aber wir verlieren hier
das was in monaten aufgebaut haben wir
uns viele andere länder beneiden
der fleisch auch noch mal zu ihnen wenn
es solche gespräche vorher gegeben hätte
zwischen dem innensenator zwischen den
berliner behörden und den dänen den
veranstaltungen dieser großdemonstration
und die hätten immer wieder gesagt ihr
könnt uns erzählen was ihr wollt ihr
können uns die regeln hier auf den tisch
legen wir werden die partout nicht
einhalten und dann sagt man als behörde
anschließender okay also wenn es so ist
dann können wir die demonstration leider
nicht genehmigen wäre das aus ihrer
sicht in ordnung gewesen oder immer noch
ein verstoß gegen die grundrechte
das verstehe ich
demonstration gegen die corinna regeln
auch so praktisch aussieht dass man
einfach keine abstandsregeln ein held
auch die maske nicht tragen will
aber nochmal das war nicht das war nicht
die alleinige begründung des inselrats
sind ein großteil der debatte entzündet
sich daran dass man merkt dass dahinter
eine politische motivation steht dass
ein innensenator in berlin sagt ich will
und das ist wörtlich ich will nicht ein
zweites mal hinnehmen dass diese leute
bei uns in der stadt demonstrieren halte
ich für eine enorme aussage und die kann
ich mir nur so erklären dass in berlin
das ja übrigens das experimentierfeld
für die neue koalition rot-rot-grün ist
die wir ja auch im bund jetzt gerade
angepriesen bekommen das in berlin
mittlerweile man einfach dran gewöhnt
ist sich an recht und gesetz im senat
nicht mehr zu halten die man ich den
deckel ja auch gesehen hat legal illegal
scheißegal das ist offenbar das motto
von rot-rot-grün erlaubt aber reicht das
auch das hat herr geißler heute so ein
bisschen anklingen lassen na wir haben
uns die leute ja schon einmal angeguckt
auf der straße also das muss wirklich
reichen nicht noch ein zweites mal
also hier ist der gesunde
menschenverstand einzusetzen
die selbst wenn die veranstalter der
demonstration ankündigen würden dass sie
sich bemühen
also die abstandsregeln und die maske
nicht umzusetzen wie wahrscheinlich ist
es denn dass diejenigen die gegen die
masken pflicht und die also abstände
demonstrieren wollen sich daran halten
das ist doch komplett realitätsfremd und
über die ich finde es unangemessen im
rahmen anderer deutschen damals für die
pandemie bekämpfung der wichtigen frage
ständig über rot-rot-grün oder berliner
sonders verhältnisse oder was zu reden
das ist doch voll im verhältnis billiger
also das hat ja noch zeit völlig
unerheblich ist er damit nichts zu tun
die frage ist ob es inhaltlich
berechtigt ist in anbetracht der
tatsache dass wir größte mühe haben eine
welle eine demonstration ab zu sagen wo
es wahrscheinlich ist weil die
teilnehmer sich so ja mal artikulieren
dass die kampagne mit schutzmaßnahmen
auf die wir alle angewiesen nicht
eingehalten werden das finde ich
vollkommen logisch alles andere
sich also überraschen und jetzt ist sie
über berliner rot-rot-grünen das
verhältnis zu spekulieren oder was auch
immer
das finde ich persönlich mühselig und
nicht passend für diese wichtige frage
na ja selbst wenn wir annehmen sollten
die würden sich da teilweise anstecken
die würden sich total daneben benehmen
würden keine einzige regel einhalten
sind vielleicht am ende 20.000 leute da
am samstag und wie gesagt es gibt danach
infektionen ist das wirklich so dass das
unser land dass das auch berlin nicht
aushalten würde
dafür haben wir ganz klare regeln und
die regeln sagen dass eine solche
demonstration hätte mit klaren auflagen
mit klaren hinweisen auch genehmigt
werden können es steht die entscheidung
vor dem gericht aus im übrigen ob diese
demonstration stattfindet oder nicht und
wenn man sich an diese regeln eben nicht
hält dann ist eine solche demonstration
auch umgehend aufzulösen und das muss
mit den veranstaltern im feuer geregelt
werden und die polizei ist in der summe
in berlin hat 7000 demonstrationen im
jahr glaube ich sehr erfahren um damit
auch umzugehen und einsatztaktisch dass
auch hinzubekommen aber in zeiten wo wir
alle auf grund und freiheitsrechte auch
am anfang dieser pandemie wie ich finde
zu recht verzichtet haben uns
einschränken lassen haben und wir zug um
zug diese freiheit und grundrechte uns
wieder zurückgeholt haben mit
gegenseitiger rücksichtnahme auch was
die frage des anderen betrifft
gesundheitsschutz wie gene schutz
abstand halten maske tragen all das ist
richtig aber das bedeutet eben auch dass
das was jetzt möglich sein muss auch
umgesetzt wird und nicht mit einer
politischen begründung einfach
weggewischt wird weil man die annahme
hat dass es schiefgehen könnte bekommen
wir denn da hin
der fleischhauer wir die wir in berlin
wohnen wissen wie es im görlitzer park
aussieht vielleicht auch am kotti
aussieht welche regelverstöße ist ja
doch da regelmäßig gibt passt das
zusammen für sie dort auf der einen
seite lässt man es laufen auf der
anderen seite greift dann der staat mit
ganzer härte durch und verbietet die
demonstration
also ich lebe ja in münchen und mag man
auch sagen ja gut möglich war immer so
ein bisschen ruhiger
das war sie auch von freunden und den
kollegen aus berlin höhere das
eigentlich mittlerweile fast jede rave
party wieder möglich ist dass ist jetzt
an bestimmte türen klopfen muss und man
kommt unten in den club rhein wo 150
leute schwitzen
natürlich ohne maske feiern und
mitgründer kümmert auch keinen berlin
das auch der einen seite zu wissen und
dann auf der andern seite ebenso sagen
nee also dass mit diesen 20.000 leute da
auf freiem feld das geht überhaupt nicht
da muss ich sagen da riecht man doch
daran dass da das da politische
motivation hinter steht und das ist
ehrlich gesagt glaube ich ziemlich
befindet und auch ziemlich dämlich von
herrn geisel
das ärgert an ja auch so daran dass er
genau diesen leuten die auch ihrem wahn
system leben und sich von diesem staat
abgewendet haben und da irgendwelche
verschwörungstheorien zugewandt jetzt
auch noch alle möglichen begründung
liefert eine frei haus widum kann man
eigentlich sein würden sie haben ja zu
dieser demonstration gehen würden sie
mit demonstrieren ich gehe grundsätzlich
wenig auf demonstration ich gehe nicht
auf demonstrationen wo nachts mitlaufen
du ich übrigens auch nicht auf
demonstration mit ihr wo irgendwelche
hardcore antisemiten und palästinenser
freunde dabei die daran teil die alle
gemeinsam gegen rechts heißen ich guck
mir schon an mit wem ich demonstriere
und da ich ja nicht ausschließen kann
dass dann von dort sind die merkwürdige
ideen haben demonstriert ich in der
regel nicht der fleischhauer sowieso
nicht auf eine demonstration aber auf
die schon gar nicht er sei ja vermutlich
werden sie am samstag auch nicht dabei
gewesen nein natürlich nicht mit der
identischen begründung der fleischhauer
gebracht hat dh lauterbach sind zwei
ihren fleischhauer sebastian czaja die
sagen beide lasst das doch stattfindet
wir werden so vernünftig oder wie auch
immer gewesen wir wären ja sowieso nicht
hingegangen aber das recht hätten wir
halt gern gehabt
ja was seine position niemand vertreten
kann sich find ich einfach nicht im
ansatz auch nur überzeugend also werden
wir diese demonstrationen zulassen dann
also müssen wir eben mit zweierlei maß
also wir gehen dann hin und sagen dass
die kinder also sozusagen sich auf dem
weg zur schule mit der maske bewegen
müssen in nrw sogar im unterricht selbst
die maske tragen muss
dass wir also reiserückkehrer 14 tage in
quarantäne setzen wenn sie gerade aus
einem risikogebiet kommen lassen wir das
hier laufen weil wir sagen das ist jetzt
die demonstration gegen die regeln die
die grundlage all der anderen einstecken
sind das ist schlicht das gas- und
unlogisch und das wird der bürger
natürlich ausschließen
der bürger wird ja spüren dass das eine
absolut unlogisch also vorgehensweise
ist und hallo wenn ich jetzt die
demonstration auflösen was ja das
wahrscheinliche ergebnis wäre dann haben
wir einen stundenlangen bereit belasten
der polizei und wir haben wahrscheinlich
das gleiche ansteckungsrisiko zu wissen
nicht auf blut werden
somit ist es der gesunde
menschenverstand er zeigt ihr wird es
nicht gelingen die sicherheitsmaßnahmen
zu gewährleisten wahrscheinlich wäre das
sogar dann der fall wenn die an wenn die
veranstalter ankündigen würden sie
wollten weil ich weiss ja das ziel darf
ich da wir mit der argumentation die sie
jetzt vertreten müssten wir davon
ausgehen dass demnächst in sämtlichen
bundesländern wieder rechtsverordnung
erlassen werden die das
demonstrationsrecht massiv einschränkt
das wäre die logische konsequenz aus
ihrer neuen situation heraus egal wer
für was argumentiert und auf der straße
geht nein das stimmt nicht das ist also
definitiv falsch ich bin gegen eine
veränderung des demonstrationsrechtes
das demonstrationsrecht lässt aber diese
einschränkung die wir eben hier so
gezogen haben nämlich wenn die
sicherheit der demonstration nicht
gewährleistet werden dass dann die
demonstration abgesagt wird nach prüfung
das lässt das bestehende
demonstrationsrecht du das möchte ich
auch nicht verändert wissen und ich
möchte nicht dass das jetzt also sage ja
mal mit einer verschwörungstheorie gar
nicht aus einer durch die hintertür
eingeführt veränderung oder verschärfung
des demonstrationsrechtes diffamiert
wird es geht um das bestehende
demonstrationsrecht das gibt diese
möglichkeit her und es ist ganz gut dass
das jetzt überprüft hat ich finde es
richtig dass das durch die rechtsorgane
geprüft wird auch gerne bis zum
bundesverfassungsgericht aber das
demonstrationsrecht wird hier nicht und
laufen sondern es wird genutzt um diese
begründen und das ist aus meiner sicht
noch richtig und es würde auch überprüft
selbst wenn sie es nicht richtig finden
würden wir gehen einmal nach dem wir
ganz viel über die der dozenten
gesprochen haben einmal zu ein paar
menschen die da am samstag hätten gerne
demonstrieren wollen und zu unserem
reporter peter wege der dort heute vom
kanzleramt wo nämlich einige von denen
gerade campieren schon seit tagen
campieren ein bisschen sich umgehört hat
und natürlich auch mit denen dort
gesprochen hat was die denken über das
berliner demonstrationsverbot
wir stehen hier direkt vor dem zelt
berger der gruppierung querdenken die
eben auch diese proteste am wochenende
jetzt für den samstag dann auch schon
die anfang august organisiert haben die
campieren hier schon seit über einer
woche rund um den reichstag und rund ums
kanzleramt haben ihre zelte
aufgeschlagen zuerst waren sie drüben
vor dem kanzleramt
da wurden sie aber am samstag geräumt
und sind nun hierher gezogen
wir sind direkt heute nachdem das
bekannt geworden ist mit dem verbot
hierher gekommen um mit den leuten mit
den bewohnern dieses camps darüber zu
sprechen und was sie uns gesagt haben da
können wir jetzt einmal kurz reinhören
ich finde auch die begründung sind
einfach absolut unhaltbar im vorhinein
schon zu sagen dass die abstände nicht
eingehalten werden wenn andere
demonstrationen zugelassen werden auch
in ähnlichen zeiträumen wo die zahlen
auch ähnlich sind bei black liner
demonstration
es ist einfach soll man man muss ja
schon irgendwo sehen dass da ein stück
weit mit zweierlei maß gemessen wird
auch und das beim letzten mal die
abstände nicht eingehalten wurden und
die massen nicht getragen wurden
eine andere demonstration das kann man
ja nicht im vorhinein sagen das ist
diesmal definitiv wieder so ist ihr
wisst wo das endet nach china oder guckt
nach meldung dass da gerade los ist
das wird so enden wir werden maximal
also aller grundrechte beraubt und
ich kann nur an alle schlafen
appellieren wacht auf ansonsten in drei
jahren seid ihr in einer ganz netten
diktatur aber der die zelte wurden jetzt
fürs wochenende auch verboten hat auch
immer verboten wird
wenn unrecht zu recht wird wird
widerstand pflicht da wie sie ihnen ein
zwei fragen zu den gründen verbot
stellen was halten sie davon
eigentlich nicht sagen natürlich halten
natürlich nichts davon werden sie
trotzdem kommen wäre natürlich werde ich
das zentrum
womit rechnen sie von seiten der polizei
ja ich hoffe mit zufrieden ja ja genau
jetzt haben wir da gerade die stimmen
der demonstranten und der bewohner
dieses zeltlagers gehört da ist die
ansage ganz klar man lässt sich da nicht
beeindrucken von diesem verbot und will
trotzdem hier am wochenende
demonstrieren einer der bewohner sprach
gegenüber uns auch von einer
kriegserklärung sogar und da ist die
richtung ganz klar man geht trotzdem zu
der demonstration und sieht das als eine
vorverurteilung die nicht gerechtfertigt
ist dass man sich nicht an die regeln
halten möchte außerdem wurde ja auch
bekannt dass dieses zeltlager verboten
werden soll fürs wochenende dass das
wohl geht dann geräumt werden muss und
auch da war die ansage der
pressesprecherin dieser versammlung hier
ganz klar wir bleiben hier wir gehen
hier nicht weg und da wird schon klar
wir können das auch im hintergrund sehen
dieses plakat mit sperrt sie endlich weg
und auf dem plakat sind die mächtigen
die entscheider dieser corona krise zu
sehen aber auch eben bill gates also die
tendenz bei manchen demonstranten auch
in richtung dass man da eine
verschwörung eine diktatur
hinter dieser corona krise sieht der
mächtigen und das bietet natürlich jetzt
dieses verbot hier den demonstranten die
chance sich als kämpfer für das
grundgesetz ein zulauf zu spielen zu
zeigen und ja danke peter vor dass
demonstrierenden demonstranten camp dort
die frage direkt einmal an karl
lauterbach peter wege sagt die fühlen
sich jetzt als märtyrer sozusagen ja die
führen jetzt im kampf gegen die
mächtigen die ihnen das spiel da
verdorben haben und das ganze bleibt
möglicherweise verschwörungstheorien
noch weiter voran
was antworten sie was kann gut zahlen
aber mit diesem risiko muss man dann
tatsächlich umgehen also da kann man
sich jetzt nicht abreißen lassen wir
können nicht unsere eigene logik der
pandemie bekämpfung der disposition
stellen weil wir angst haben dass ein
paar menschen also die
verschwörungstheorien anhängen sich
jetzt noch mal bestätigt fühlen also es
ist tatsächlich so dass
wir das machen müssen was um
infektionsschutz und was epidemiologisch
geboten ist und wir sind hier nicht die
psychotherapeutin einer kleinen gruppe
von empathie also möglicherweise sich
jetzt bestätigt die möglicherweise
abwegigen ideen also das ist für mich
akzeptiert das muss man den menschen
lassen
wenn das auch beim einen oder anderen
dazu geführt dass er da an sich noch
bestätigt wird in der warenwelt der
unterwegs sagen dass wir nicht alle aber
werden es ein paar geben dann ist das so
damit muss man leben dass es ein
management problem aber wir können nicht
unsere bevölkerung im stich lassen die
vielen vernünftigen die von uns
verlangen dass die entwicklung zahlen zu
niedrig am beginn der zweiten rallye
gehalten werden wie wir das erreichen
dann ohne eine unzulässige einschränkung
der rot
lauterbach sebastian czaja sie kennen
berlin besser als wir alle sie können
vielleicht ein bisschen einschätzen was
da am wochenende passiert also die mit
denen wir heute gesprochen haben haben
alle gesagt wir kommen trotzdem haben
sie viele zuschauer leser bei uns
gemeldet die auch gesagt haben also das
lassen wir uns nicht verbieten das heißt
worauf müssen wir uns in der hauptstadt
einstellen wird das ein sehr
anstrengender möglicherweise auch
gewalttätiger samstag können wir auf
eine deeskalationsstrategie setzen und
hoffen wir haben eine sehr routinierte
polizei in berlin die mit solchen fragen
umgehen kann ich habe es ja schon gesagt
wir haben fünf bis 7000 demonstrationen
jedes jahr in der stadt berlin ist eben
auch magnet für so etwas als hauptstadt
dass man sich mit so was dann auch
auskennt und deeskalierend auch den
gegenübertritt das wie eine eskalation
haben
daran sind nicht die berliner beamten
schuld in irgendeiner art und weise
sondern ihr oberster dienstherr der der
meinung war er müsse mit einer
politischen begründung hier die stimmung
eher noch anheizen und ich teile die
einschätzung dass das eher wasser auf
die mühlen ist und wir müssten viel mehr
deeskalierend wirken weil am ende haben
wir als gesellschaften gemeinsames ziel
und das heißt aber was sie ihre
befürchtung ganz ganz schnell was die
befürchtung fürs wochenende dass das
deeskalierend ist oder das ist eskaliert
ja das ist durchaus einsatztaktischen
herausforderung wird
weil sich ja war ja unklar ist wo gibt
es sammelpunkte wie entwickelt sich das
und deshalb bleibt abzuwarten aber mit
grosser ich sage auch mit einer
ordentlichen polizeipräsenz dafür zu
sorgen dass entsprechend eine
deeskalation möglich ist so wie man es
im übrigen hätte auch machen müssen bei
einer demonstration die man genehmigt
hätte und dann wenn auflagen nicht
eingehalten worden wären tatsächlich ja
auch die demonstration hätte auflösen
müssen das hätten wir natürlich sage ich
auch für die freien demokraten genauso
gesehen letztes wort hat jan
fleischhauer bei uns in der runde karl
lauterbach hat ganz oft das wort
gesunder menschenverstand benutzt und
hat gesagt der gesunde menschenverstand
sagt doch dass diese demonstration von
leuten die eben ganz gezielt diese
regeln brechen wollen nicht stattfinden
darf wenn man jetzt gerade das was an
corinna regeln beschlossen wurde im land
oder wie die praxis gelebt wird das
vielleicht nicht immer als gesunden
menschenverstand versteht und das gefühl
hat dagegen demonstrieren zu müssen
dagegen was sagen zu wollen was ist
eigentlich das richtige ausdruck mittel
wenn zumindest in berlin ich gehe zu
demonstrieren ihren fleischauer da gibt
es ja viele kann sich ja auch im block
und ich gehör verschaffen
aber ich habe jetzt mal aus der
diskussion entnommen dass karl
lauterbach von der spd auch auf unserer
seite wäre wenn es beim nächsten mal
wieder heißt gegen rassismus gegen
rechts
dann lagen wir die bild runde ein und
dann wird ja auch ein flammendes
plädoyer dafür halten warum man die
antirassismus stimmung ebenfalls
verbieten müsse so das ist so ist es so
ist es aber vielleicht gelingt es ja
auch alle demonstrationen einfach
stattfinden zu lassen vielleicht halten
wir die aale aus vielleicht ist das ja
auch eine lösung wenn auch nicht für ein
lauter war ja also ich würde es ist
einiges wenn man so aus dem haus heraus
bewegt was man nicht mehr so ganz
versteht also wenn ich jetzt von vorne
die mit fotos abgeschickt haben von dem
letzten reise von berlin nach wien in
einem voll gepackten deutsche bahn ece
waggon wo die leute sogar auf dem boden
saßen ja also wie die hölzer team so
dicht beieinander
und gleichzeitig im kino ein bisschen
jetzt immer drei plätze frei bleiben ja
und war so einer freiluft demo sagt man
riesen ansteckungsrisiko ich kriege es
nicht mehr ganz zusammen
ich habe das gefühl so ganz weiß man
nicht in berlin
was man tut ich kriege es nicht mehr
zulassen sagt jan fleischhauer dass es
das schlusswort in dieser runde karl
lauterbach hat gesagt er hält nichts
davon die psychotherapeutin dieser leute
zu sein die da am samstag hätten auf die
straße gehen wollen